Wenn Leute wissen, dass du bei Schalke spielst, dann nehmen sie es auch ein bisschen ernster, weil E-Sport in Deutschland jetzt nicht so angesehen ist, aber als Schalke reinkam, wurde es auf jeden Fall besser angesehen.
Der Markt für Computerspiele in Deutschland ist etwa 4 Milliarden Euro schwer. Wenn man das in Vergleich setzt zum Bundesliga-Fußball, ist das schon wesentlich größer, weil die Bundesliga im letzten Jahr etwa 2, 6 Milliarden umgesetzt hat.
Fußball gehört auf den grünen Rasen und hat mit anderen Dingen, die computermäßig sind, nichts zu tun. Ja, das halte ich für absurd.
Ich bin ein großer Freund des E-Sports als Sport. Warum? Weil es hat ganz viele Facetten des Sports. 300 Bewegungen etwa pro Minute, das ist schon richtig Sport. Ich habe taktische, soziale, also interaktive Fähigkeiten. Ich muss also mich abstimmen, ich muss Spiele lernen, ich muss schnell reagieren und vor allen Dingen mich auch absprechen. All das ist für mich Sport.
Also die DFL, wie meinst du das jetzt, in Sachen Suchtprävention?
Nee, jetzt in Sachen, was es erstmal gibt im E-Sport-Bereich.
Ah, okay. Ja, also es ist keine eigene Liga, zumindest noch nicht. Die DFL hat einen Modus im Spiel FIFA 18 integriert. Das haben sie zusammen mit Electronic Arts gemacht, mit EA Sports. Und da gibt es also dann eine offizielle deutsche Meisterschaft, bei der wir jetzt am Wochenende eben bei dem Finale waren, Samstag und Sonntag. Malte war mit dabei als Analyst dann noch ein Kollege von Malte, der Benni. Wir haben dann zusammen kommentiert. Das lief, wie schon gesagt, auf Sport 1. Und das ist aber das Finale über zwei Tage. Davor gibt es eben verschiedene Möglichkeiten, sich dafür zu qualifizieren. Das Ganze geht los kurz nach Release von dem aktuellen FIFA Spiel mit Online-Qualifikationsturnieren. Das heißt, jeder, der das Spiel hat, kann einen Bundesligaverein picken, den er repräsentiert. Beispielsweise, keine Ahnung, der Klub geht ja nicht, weil es der zweite Liga noch. Nehmen wir Schalke 04, weil wir Tim mit dabei haben. Dann sage ich also, ich spiele in Königsblau. Und habe dann so ein Team, das genormt ist. Also alle Mannschaften sind dann genormt, alle Spieler sind gleich stark. 85, die Gesamtwertung. Und dann spielt man dort, muss eine bestimmte Anzahl an Spielen absolvieren. Und wenn man sich dort eben gut behauptet, kommt man eine Runde weiter und so weiter und so fort. Dazu gesellen sich dann auch Offline-Turniere, also Turniere, wo man hinfahren kann, um sich eben eine Teilnahme zu sichern bei dem großen Finale. Und das kommt dann eben alles zusammen. Und das geht dann über Monate hinweg. Erst die Online-Phase, dann verschiedene Offline-Turniere. Dann gibt es nochmal die Playoffs direkt bevor es zum Finale geht. Die haben in Düsseldorf stattgefunden. Und dort kristallisiert sich dann heraus, wer die besten 24 Spieler sind. Die sind gemixt eben aus verschiedenen Wildcard-Turnieren, aus Online-Qualifikanten und Offline-Qualifikanten. Und die treten dann an zwei Tagen an. Und am Ende gibt es dann eben eine Gruppenphase. Da sind es dann vier Gruppen gewesen auf den beiden Konsolen Xbox One und PlayStation 4. Und dann gibt es eine KO-Phase, wie man es halt kennt, aus einer normalen WM-EM. Und am Ende gibt es ein Finale. Und derjenige, der gewinnt, der bekommt dann eben die Trophäe. Das ist so eine kleine Meisterschale quasi und 25.000 Euro. Und ist offizieller deutscher Meister. Sozusagen lizenziert oder verifiziert durch die deutsche Fußballliga. Also schon ein sehr großer und wichtiger Titel. Ich würde fast behaupten, auch der größte national gesehen. Es gibt noch die ESL-Meisterschaft, die ausgewürfelt wird oder ausgespielt wird. Gewürfelt klingt wieder böse, ja ich weiß. Da ist jetzt auch ein Wochenende. Ich weiß noch nicht, wann dieses Tribünengespräch erscheint, aber jetzt am Wochenende am Samstag wird dann auch dort der Meister der Frühlings-Saison, der Spring-Season, bekannt gegeben. Das ist das, was die DFL macht, aber das ist erst einmal nur so der Modus. Sie machen ja auch dazu, überlegen sie sich immer, wie können wir denn noch mehr Bundesliga-Vereine dazu bewegen, sich vielleicht im E-Sport zu engagieren. Deswegen gibt es eben auch in diesem Jahr neu Wildcards für Vereine. Man hat sich also überlegt, welche Bundesliga-Vereine haben vielleicht Lust, mal E-Sports in irgendeiner Form auszuprobieren, ohne vielleicht gleich einen eigenen Spieler zu verpflichten und den unter Vertrag zu nehmen und den zu coachen und so weiter. Und da gab es halt auch eben das erste Mal die Möglichkeit. Ich glaube, Gladbach war mit dabei, die haben so ein Wildcard-Tournee veranstaltet. Da ist auch ein Spieler dann eben beim großen Finale mit dabei gewesen. Und ich glaube schon, dass die DFL – es ist nur eine Vermutung, kein Wissen – dass die schon bestrebt ist, da vielleicht irgendwann mal, wenn das hinhaut, eine Art Legensystem virtuell hinzubekommen. Aber das, denke ich, dauert noch ein bisschen, weil es ja auch einige Vereine gibt, die im Moment sehr vehement dagegen sind, sich dazu engagieren. Deswegen leider auch zwei große, zumindest ein großer, der BVB, ist da nicht so angetan.
Das Interessante ist, in Frankreich und den Niederlanden zum Beispiel sind die Vereine dazu verpflichtet, ein E-Sport-Team zu haben. Und wenn ich vorhin gesagt habe, fast alle Major League Soccer-Vereine, also der US-amerikanischen Fußballliga, haben einen Verein, dann ist es auch noch eine Frage der Zeit bis die letzten beiden. Die haben nur noch jetzt keinen gefunden. Da ging die Saison jetzt gerade los. Da ist es quasi auch in einer Kooperation mit dem Spielehersteller fix geworden, dass jeder Verein ein E-Sport-Team haben soll. Und der BVB, der hat dazu unter anderem das Zitat geliefert, auch wenn wir Hollywood-Filme und Bücher als Bereicherung empfinden, würde der BVB keine Schauspieler oder Autorengruppen als eigenes Team verpflichten. Auch wenn es sich als Lukratie für eine größere Zielgruppe erweisen würde. Es passt nicht zu uns als Fußballverein. Wir empfinden es für uns nicht als authentisch und echt. Andere Clubs werden dies naturgemäß anders bewerten. Welche anderen Clubsthemen könnten damit gemeint sein?
Alle anderen? Ich glaube, jetzt haben 16 von 18 Vereinen an dieser virtuellen Bundesliga auf irgendeine Art und Weise teilgenommen. Von daher sagt ja schon relativ viel aus. Und die Argumentation hier, lasse ich mal so stehen.
Ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt, ja, das mag vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Wahrheit entsprechen, das Zitat gerade. Aber ich glaube, das hat auch noch andere Ebenen. Und zwar, ich glaube, das ist immer noch der Fall. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Aber der BVB hat eine Clubpartnerschaft mit Konami, dem Spielehersteller von Pro-Volution-Zocker. Da haben wir das Spiel nochmal. Und alle großen E-Sports-Wettbewerbe im virtuellen Fußball finden aber in FIFA statt. Weil eben über die DFL und über die FIFA dort die Lizenzen offiziell vergeben sind. Und das ist eben sehr nah an der Fußball-Lizenzlogik auch angelehnt. Und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass das auch noch ein großer Faktor ist, warum sich der BVB eben jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei der virtuellen Bundesliga, bei dieser Club Wildcats noch nicht integriert hat, weil sie eben da mit Konami noch eine Kooperation am Laufen haben. Ja, sehr guter und ich glaube richtiger Punkt. Aber jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage, Malte, ist das denn spannend, so eine virtuelle Bundesliga? Denn das, finde ich, ist der große Unterschied zwischen der Fußballsimulation FIFA und anderen großen E-Sport-Spielen, wie eben, wir haben sie alle schon genannt, Dota 2, League of Legends, Counter-Strike GO und so weiter und so fort. Nämlich bei FIFA sehe ich einfach nur ein Fußballspiel und das geht genauso manchmal eins zu null aus mit dem Tor in der ersten Minute wie in echtes Fußballspiel auch. Und so wie ich dem echten Sportfußball da Probleme attestiere mit Blick auf die Zukunft, auf kürzere Aufmerksamkeit spannen und so weiter und so fort, so sehe ich das im E-Sport-Bereich aus. Wenn ich mir – ich als Laie, also ein paar der Spiele kannte ich, aber zum Beispiel der ganze Dota-League of Legends-Bereich, das ist nicht meins. Habe ich nie gespielt, das heißt da stehe ich erstmal davor, wie es achala wenn es blitzt, hat man bei uns im Franken immer gesagt, also wie das Eichhörnchen wenn es blitzt. Verstehe ich erstmal gar nichts. Aber es packt mich, weil da passiert wahnsinnig viel. Ich verstehe noch nicht alles, aber es ist komprimiert auf einen kurzen Zeitraum. Am plakativsten ist es noch bei Counter-Strike, da sind die Spiele wenige Minuten lang, also die einzelnen Spiele und es ist immer was los. Aber bei FIFA hat man das doch nicht. Ja, also ich hatte das ja eingangs schon so ein bisschen auch gesagt, dass ich das selber auch durchaus kritisch sehe. Also es hat einerseits auch Vorzüge, dass FIFA eben so einfach zu verstehen ist, weil der Fußball einfach zu verstehen ist. Und es hat auch Vorzüge, dass Fußball der beliebteste Sport ist und entsprechend auch das Interesse am Spielen sehr groß. Und man kann einfach niedrigschwelliger sich mal kurz in die Konsole setzen und eine Runde zocken, als jedes Mal, da braucht man irgendwie gleich ein paar Leute auf den Fußballplatz zu gehen. Deshalb wirklich fast alle Fußballer und Fußballerinnen auch FIFA spielen. Also das ist wichtig, um einfach mal zu zeigen, wie relevant das Spiel als solches ist, also wie oft es auch in Deutschland zum Beispiel jedes Jahr verkauft wird. Die Community ist sehr groß. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Problem aber, dass diese große Community irgendwie, wie du es gerade schon gesagt hast, auch bespaßt werden möchte. Und da gibt es eben schon ein Überangebot am Fußball, meiner Meinung nach. Also es ist halt echt krass. Man kann jeden Tag Fußballspiele gucken, Fußballtalks sich anhören. Es gibt Fußballpodcasts, die dauern Stunden. Es ist unklar. Ja, auch das.
Furchtbar so was, furchtbar.
Ganz schlimm. Und dann sollen sich die Leute auch noch virtuell den Fußball angucken. Und da sind wir eben gefragt als Berichterstatter über das Thema, wie man da Anreize schaffen kann. Und ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt. Ich denke, der eine Vorteil ist, dass FIFA kürzer ist. Also ein Spiel geht meistens zweimal sechs Minuten. Mit Taktik-Einstellungen und so weiter sind es dann 15 bis 20 Minuten pro Spielrunde. Das ist recht kurzweilig. Du hast die Aufmerksamkeit sparen angesprochen. Also da sehe ich einen Vorteil. Das merken wir auch, dass die Leute sich das gerne mal reinziehen. Kann man dann ja auch auf YouTube nochmal kurz reinklicken oder so im Nachgang. Das ist schneller angeschaut als ein ganzes Fußballspiel. Und die andere Ebene – und da muss ich eben was tun – ist, dass FIFA Vorzüge hat, das Regelwerk des Fußballs zu innovieren. Also anders als der Fußball, wo das, glaube ich, schon eher noch was sehr verankertes, sehr Traditionelles ist. Da wird es, glaube ich, dauern, bis da mal Regeln verändert werden. FIFA könnt hier sozusagen Vorreiter sein, aus meiner Sicht, und einfach mal rum experimentieren. Und ich hatte gerade das Beispiel unseres Draft-Story-Cups genannt, wo wir eben die Spieler ihre Teams draften lassen haben, was mal eine ganz neue Komponente war. Und ich glaube, da muss man einfach kreativ bleiben. Und dann haben die Leute auch Lust, sich FIFA anzuschauen, obwohl es den Fußball gibt. Und dann ergänzen sich die beiden Themen auch ganz gut, weil die Spieler im Digitalen dann eben abgebildet werden. Also man spielt ja mit echten Fußballern. Und das ist auch für die Fußballer und für die Vereine sehr cool, dann da auch nochmal auf eine innovative Art und Weise abgebildet zu sein. Ja, aber andererseits spiele ich ja in der virtuellen Bundesliga mit den echten Fußballern. Aber die haben alle denselben Wert. Das heißt, ein Jerome Boateng unterscheidet sich von einem Mitchell Weisse nur durch die Körpergröße, das Aussehen und so weiter? Ja, das ist aber eine Besonderheit in der virtuellen Bundesliga. Grundsätzlich ist das in FIFA nicht so, sondern du hattest das bei League of Legends so benannt, wie es bei FIFA tatsächlich der Fall ist. Lionel Messi ist da eben schnell, ist flink, ist hohe Abschlussstark und hat genau die Attribute und Eigenschaften, die er auch im echten Fußball hat. Also das ist schon sehr nah an dem echten Fußball orientiert. Die virtuelle Bundesliga hat das nur eingeführt, ganz kurz, um die verschiedenen Vereine eben ungefähr gleich stark sein zu lassen. Und das ist genau mein Punkt, auf den ich hinaus wollte. Denn das Problem der DFL dürfte ja sein, wenn es dieses Regularium nicht gibt, ja dann spielen die Leute logischerweise nur mit Lionel Messi, Christiano Ronaldo und so weiter. Ja, aber auch da – ich denke mal, Konni hat das vorhin auch nicht gesagt, weil das hätte sich gleich noch komplizierter angehört – beim Finalturnier gab es nochmal einen ganz anderen Modus. Und ich glaube auch, da hat die DFL und auch EA Sports als Spielehersteller ein bisschen gelernt, dass dieser 85er Modus ehrlich gesagt ziemlich langweilig ist. Es hat auch noch ein paar andere Gründe, aber das wird jetzt sehr tief in die Materie gehen. Aber allein schon, dass alle Spieler gleich stark sind. Das hat ja irgendwie gar keine Anreize mehr. Es wurde dann jetzt beim großen Finalevent der Modus Ultimate Team gespielt. Und das ist in FIFA der beliebteste Spielmodus. Da kann man sich aus allen Fußballvereinen, aus allen Fußballspielern seine Lieblingsspieler zusammenbauen zu einem Team. Man muss dann so ein bisschen aufpassen, dass die die sogenannte Chemie haben, also dass die irgendwie in einer Art und Weise miteinander harmonieren. Aber wenn sie zum Beispiel in der gleichen Liga spielen, dann harmonieren sie per se immer schon. Und in der virtuellen Bundesliga war es jetzt so, dass man pro Fußballverein drei Spieler auswählen durfte. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass ich das sehr cool finde, aus der Berichterstatter-Sicht, weil das eben sehr wild war. Da haben dann drei Bayern-Spieler in dem FIFA-Spiel, also man wählt dann entsprechend seine Elf-Spieler plus die Ersatzbank. Da haben drei Bayern-Spieler mit drei Schalke-Spielern und drei Dortmund-Spielern gespielt. Und so hat man da sehr kreative Teams gesehen. Meine Frage an dich nur, Tim, wäre mal, wie ihr das eigentlich seht, dass auf einmal die Markenidentität da auch so ein ganz bisschen angekratzt wird, indem nämlich auf einmal doch ein Schalker mit einem Dortmunder spielt?
Wenn ich tatsächlich jetzt hier sagen würde, nein, das muss dann aber alles total Schalke-Brand sein, dann müsste ich viele Argumente von mir komplett widerlegen. Wir müssen uns einfach den Gegebenheiten hier anpassen und schauen, dass es auch attraktiv für den Zuschauer, für den Spieler usw. ist. Und so funktioniert es im FIFA-Bereich am besten. Und ich glaube, deshalb ist es für uns auch relativ unproblematisch, weil es soll ja ein Spielerlebnis sein und soll auch ein Zuschauerlebnis sein. Und wir wollen doch nicht zwingend alles hier kopieren, was im Fußball Status quo ist. Und ich glaube, das ist völlig unproblematisch für uns gewesen. Eins muss ich dabei sagen, ich bin ganz froh, wenn unsere Jungs keine Dortmund-Spiele haben.
So etwas habe ich mir schon fast gedacht. Und ich muss fairerweise noch dazu sagen, in der virtuellen Bundesliga war die Auswahl des Kaders auf die Bundesligaspieler beschränkt. Aber bei internationalen Wettbewerben kann man wirklich aus dem Ganzen schöpfen. Und da spielen dann fast alle Profis wirklich nur mit den Topstars. Also da spielt dann im Schalke Dress Christiane Ronaldo oder auch Legenden, die man spielt.
Und das ist auch schön zu sehen. Also ein guter Bulli oder ein Ronaldo.
Also das dann ein Ronaldo spielen, das finde ich dann auch wieder schön. Also ich glaube, das wird sich einfach auch noch so ein bisschen eingrooven. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich glaube, hier wird wirklich auf vielen Ebenen angesetzt und überlegt, wie das Produkt attraktiv sein kann, wie das für einen Zuschauer kurzweilig und spaßig sein kann. Und ich glaube, da kann der Fußball tatsächlich noch was lernen.
Ich würde gerne noch eine Sache ergänzend sagen, weil wir jetzt eben FIFA Ultimate Team angesprochen haben, der Modus, wo man eben alles zusammenholen kann. Das klingt jetzt bei Malte so, als könnte jeder sozusagen jederzeit alle Spiele auswählen. Das ist halt die Komponente, die es dann auch nochmal anspruchsvoll macht, denn diese Spiele kannst du natürlich nicht einfach frei zusammenstellen. Gut, die Pros schon, aber du als eigener Spieler musst dir diese Spielkarten – sind das ja eigentlich – erspielen oder erkaufen, je nachdem. Also es gibt halt diese Mannschaft wird zusammengestellt durch fiktive Karten, die du zusammenstellst und die musst du dir quasi erst erspielen oder erkaufen. Das macht es dann halt ein bisschen nochmal anspruchsvoller zuzugucken, weil der Zuschauer denkt sich, wer passt denn in mein Team vorne noch in der Sturmspitze ganz gut? Wie macht es denn der Spieler so und so? Welche Karten lege ich da nochmal drauf? Man kann nämlich diese Karten auch nochmal zu einem bestimmten Stürmertypus machen und so. Also es gibt schon noch Komponenten, fernab, alle haben 85, was wir eben hatten in den Online-Qualifikationsrunden und diesem FIFA-Ultimate-Team, das ist nochmal ein ganz ganz anderer Unterschied irgendwie so, auch, das haben wir auch gemerkt jetzt am Wochenende bei der Virtua in der Bundesliga, dass natürlich einige der Aufstellungen ähnlich sind, also ein Goretzka war immer mit dabei, jeder hatte Goretzka, ich kann mich an kein einziges Spiel erinnern, wo Goretzka gefehlt hätte, aber dann gibt es eben doch ein paar Variationen, wo man dann eben auch als Zuschauer lernen kann, der auch selber spielt, wer passt denn eventuell noch in mein Team rein und das macht den Modus dann eben, da sind wir bei dem Punkt EA, versucht da schon glaube ich noch ein bisschen eine Varianz zum Zum klassischen Fußballspiel eben über Foot zu bewirken. Wie kann ich denn mein Team zusammenstellen? Und das ist glaube ich auch aus Zuschauersperspektive, zumindest wenn man das Spiel selber spielt, auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Was bestimmt auch schon vielen Hörern und Hörern über den Weg gelaufen sein wird, bei ihren eigenen Lieblingsvereinen und vielleicht auch auf den Social-Media-Kanälen von anderen Vereinen, ist, dass alle Bundesliga-Vereine oder fast alle diesen Hype mit befeuern. Das heißt, man hat immer wieder Bilder, wo die echten Spieler ihre FIFA-Bewertung in die Kamera halten. Oder bei Instagram kann man sich nicht retten vor FIFA-Content. Und auch die Medienkonni machen da sehr, sehr aktiv mit. Also es ist unglaublich, welcher Hype um die neuen Werte, also wenn die Spieler ihre Updates erhalten und dann man eben gucken kann, wer ist in welchem Bereich besser oder schlechter geworden, da gibt es Klickstrecken auf Sportportalen. Es gibt eine eigene Kicker-E-Sport-Seite. Das ist unglaublich, welcher Hype um dieses Thema herum erzeugt wird. Und manchmal ist mir das aber persönlich, obwohl ich mich schon als noch dieser Gedankenwelt zugehörig bezeichnen würde, mir ist das manchmal zu viel. Jetzt brauchen wir jetzt auch Klickstrecken da. Also reicht es nicht, dass wir schon die Klickstrecken haben, das verdienen die Topstars im internationalen Fußball. Welche Rolle ist das?
Das sind die Spielerfrauen.
Oder so sexy sind unsere Handballsternchen.
Ich sage mal so, Klickstrecken an sich kann man generell hinterfragen. Das ist, glaube ich, kein Ding des E-Sports.
Ja, aber welche Rolle spielen da die Medien?
Denn letztlich setzen sie sich ja in eine – Also es bildet sich da eine Allianz zwischen einem Spielehersteller, der sehr gutes Geld damit verdient und sowohl Vereinen, die damit auch versuchen, Geld zu verdienen, und aber auch Medien, die ja auch berichten sollen. Und es ist nicht so, dass der E-Sport ein komplett unkritischer Bereich ist. Ich will ihn jetzt auch nicht schlimmer zeichnen als er ist, aber es gibt auch im E-Sport Betrug, es gab schon Dopingfälle, wir haben das ganze Thema der Spielsucht. Und in keinem anderen Bereich würde man das so akzeptieren, dass die Medien sich zum, ja, weiß nicht, fast so zum Steigbügel halten.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass die Berichterstattung zu positiv verläuft in Summe?
Ja, beziehungsweise stelle ich mir häufig die Frage. Sie berichten natürlich darüber, weil es eine Aufmerksamkeit hat, aber es gibt auch ganz viele Artikel, wo ich mir denke, okay, vielleicht war das jetzt auch nur ein Gefallen an den Spielehersteller EA, der ja auch Anzeigen schaltet in Medien oder vielleicht fließt da auch direkt manchmal Geld in Form von sogenannten Medienkooperationen.
Also das ist ja jetzt auch wiederum kein Thema, was der eSport exklusiv hat. Also so eine Nähe zu Herstellern, zu Werbetreibenden und so weiter, das gibt es ja auch schon in anderen Bereichen. Genauso machst du dich ja – jeder Bundesligaverein will natürlich auch Geld verdienen, wenn du also darüber berichtest und du weißt auch, wie es abläuft, wenn du mal ein Interview mit Thomas Müller bekommst, da wirst du in der Tendenz eher nicht so kritisch über den FC Bayern München berichten, weil dann war es dein letztes Interview mit Thomas Müller. Das ist – naja, ist so.
Warte mal, wenn ich Thomas Müller habe, der wird gegrillt von mir.
Ne, was ich damit sagen will, ist, es ist natürlich immer ein gewisses Fingerspitzengefühl gefragt und es gibt immer – du musst immer abwägen, was du machst, aber was bezahlte Kooperationen angeht, will ich mal hoffen, dass zumindest die Arbeitgeber, für die ich arbeite, in dem Fall Sport1 in Sachen E-Sports, dass sie das dann kennzeichnen würden. Ich stecke da natürlich nicht dahinter. Ich schreibe da jetzt nicht so viele Artikel. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es läuft.
Ja, ich habe dich an die Hand genommen und in ein vermintes Gebiet geführt.
Oh ja.
Ja, aber es gibt doch auch – ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt – Pressekodex oder sowas, also dass sich auch Verlage und Medienhäuser ganz sauber ihre Werte dort runterbrechen oder sagen, nach diesen Maßstäben arbeiten wir. Ich glaube, das Problem ist da auch ein bisschen größer. Das ist beim E-Sports auf vielen Ebenen immer wieder interessant zu sehen. Ich glaube, E-Sports ist einfach nur ein gutes Beispiel für die digitalen Entwicklungen. Und online Journalismus generell hat, glaube ich, diese Probleme, wenn man mal das Beispiel jetzt nimmt. Und E-Sports ist immer wieder nur ein Thema, was damit irgendwie im Einklang steht, weil E-Sports auch so etwas Neues ist. Und da können sich irgendwie alle ausprobieren. Und deswegen glaube ich irgendwie auch, dass es manchmal sogar ganz gut ist, wieder aus den alten Strukturen zu lernen. Ich möchte jetzt nicht bei Konni rumschleimen, aber ich habe zum Beispiel gemerkt, dass seine Art wie er FIFA-kommentiert sehr aus dem Fußball kommt und dass das dem FIFA-Kommentarber gut tut, weil wir manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen zu nördig da rangegangen sind, zu kleinteilig. Und genauso kann man auf ganz vielen anderen Ebenen auch, glaube ich, aus beiden Welten lernen. Und deswegen glaube ich auch in Bezug auf den Journalismus und die Berichterstattung, wird sich das jetzt auch alles weiterentwickeln und dann wird es irgendwann genauso den kritischen Kommentar geben, wie den Journalisten, der sich da irgendwo einschleimen möchte. Und jeder muss dann halt wissen, nach welchem Maßstäben und Werten er da agiert.
Ich meine, dass EA ein Stück weit eine Art Monopolstellung hat, weil wir tatsächlich ProEVO jetzt nicht zwingen, als ernst zu nehmende Konkurrenz, was zumindest die Reichweite und die Verkaufszeiten angeht, hinnehmen können. Natürlich haben die eine Art Monopolstellung. Aber was ist die Alternative dazu, nicht darüber zu berichten? Das kann es natürlich auch nicht sein, weil natürlich die Zielgruppe da ist. Die ist interessiert. Wir merken das bei FIFA. Malte hat die Klickzahlen vom Wochenende. Wir waren auf Platz 13 der YouTube Trends am Wochenende mit dem Finale. Dann also das On-Demand-Video, was danach automatisch generiert, da steht. Die Leute wollen natürlich auch das Zeug. Es ist eigentlich so, dass wir sagen, EA zahlt. Jetzt machen wir nochmal irgendwie eine Live-Reportage dazu.
Nein, absolut, also das wird man sicherlich auch an den Downloads dieser Folge merken, dass das Thema interessiert und auch eine große Öffentlichkeit hat. Ich frage mich nur, das ist jetzt allerdings auch spekulativ, deswegen können wir dann die Argumentation hier auch schließen, aber früher war es so, es war für EA Sports, den Hersteller, ganz, ganz wichtig, dass er die Lizenzen der Bundesliga-Spieler und der anderen Vereine hatte. Er hatte ganz großes Thema, hatte Pro Evolution Soccer, der einzige Rivale, nie und unter anderem deswegen, aber auch aus ein paar anderen Gründen, hat das nicht geschafft, sich zu etablieren und jetzt hat EA Sports ein Monopol. Und ich könnte mir aber eine Zukunft vorstellen, in fünf bis vielleicht zehn Jahren, wo der E-Sport-Bereich so wichtig geworden ist, auch für die Bundesliga-Vereine, die sich darin jetzt engagieren, dass sich dieses Verhältnis umdreht, dass es für die DFL ganz, ganz wichtig ist, dass ihre Spieler in EA Sports stattfinden und dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass EA Sports betteln muss und viele Millionen dafür zahlen muss, die Lizenzen zu bekommen. Das halte ich für ein denkbares Szenario. Ich glaube nicht, weil so sind die Lizenzen nicht aufgebaut. Also ich bin da jetzt auch kein absoluter Vollprofitin, würde ich da wahrscheinlich noch besser mit den Lizenzwelten auskennen. Aber so wie ich die DFL da kennengelernt habe, haben die einfach die Rechte an diesen ganzen Themen und wissen ganz genau um die Wertigkeit. Und am Ende machen die ein Bieterverfahren alle fünf bis zehn Jahre. Und wenn EA dann die Rechte nicht mehr kaufen möchte, obwohl das super wertvoll ist für die DFL da drin zu sein, gar keine Frage, lassen sie sich aber trotzdem dafür bezahlen. Das heißt, am Ende des Tages ist die Frage, wer die Rechte erhält. Und ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie man der DFL diese Rechte entziehen soll. Aber klar, das kann natürlich sein, dass die Vereine irgendwann auch besser verstehen, dass auch diese ganze digitale Ebene irgendwie eine eigene Welt ist und sich da neue Lizenz- und Rechtelogiken ergeben. Das kann natürlich passieren. Ja, vielleicht bin ich auch einfach ein bisschen zu kritisch gegenüber allem, was ein Monopol ist. Aber wie gesagt, wir bewegen uns jetzt hier ein bisschen im Becken. Ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich finde den Punkt da gut. Ich glaube nur, dann müsste man wirklich, kann man philosophisch sehr weit ausholen. Jaja, klar. Wie, also genau, wo Monopole okay sind und so weiter, kann man die Systemfragen ansetzen. Monopole sind nur im Fußballpodcast-Bereich okay. Das ist der einzige Bereich, wo ich das sehe. Und auch nur, wenn...
Da musst du noch dran arbeiten, oder?
Ja, ja, absolut, nee, es ist nicht mal Monopol. So groß möchte ich den Rasenfunk nicht machen. Aber wenn wir jetzt schon... Wir haben jetzt sehr viel über Schalke 04 gesprochen und jetzt auch über die DFL. Ich gebe die Frage erstmal an Konni und dann darf der Tim gerne noch auch noch reingrätschen, wenn er möchte. Was machen denn eigentlich andere Bundesliga-Vereine? Ich habe ja vorhin ganz, ganz viele aufgezählt.
Ja, in der Detailarbeit weiß ich es natürlich nicht, aber es gibt inzwischen schon eine große Anzahl an Vereinen, auch aus der zweiten Liga. Ich denke an den VfL Bochum. Ich denke aber auch an den 1. FC Nürnberg. Auch der Club hat ja zwei Spieler. Da ist schon Bewegung. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wirklich in den letzten Monaten sich da sehr viel tut. Auch generell habe ich das Gefühl, dass EA eSports weiter fokussiert. Man sieht das anhand der neuen Formen der Weltmeisterschaft. Es gibt ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit diese Foot Champions Offline-Turniere, wofür man sich qualifizieren kann. Dann heißt die Weltmeisterschaft jetzt auch ein bisschen anders. Es gibt Global Series, Playoffs und so weiter. Da gibt es erst mal eine neue Struktur und auch bei den Bundesliga-Vereinen bei uns in der 1. und 2. Liga gibt es immer mehr, die sich da mit engagieren, Spieler verpflichten, unter Vertrag nehmen, teilweise auch Kooperationen. Der 1. FC Köln zum Beispiel hat ja mit SK Gaming kooperiert, einem traditionellen eSports-Team eigentlich. Er hat dann hier mit Mirza Jahic, der Vizemeister geworden ist am Wochenende bei der Virtuen Bundesliga, auch einen Spieler, der Köln repräsentiert. Also jeder Verein hat seine eigene Art und Weise mit umzugehen. Schalke, wie schon gesagt, haben wir bei Tim gehört. Die haben sogar nach Wuchs eine Art gecastet mit so einem Turnier. RB hat bei Schalke 04 den ehemaligen deutschen Meister abgeworben. Gian Jassala. Also da ist schon allein, dass es so einen Transfer gibt. Denn es war, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, auch der erste dieser Art in FIFA, in Deutschland zumindest. Da merkt man schon, welche Bedeutung das auch für die Bundesligisten bekommt.
Ja, kann ich im Prinzip alle so bestätigen. Ich glaube, das einzige Problem, was Fußballvereine oder überhaupt E-Sport-Organisationen mit FIFA haben, ist ganz grundsätzlich das Thema, dass FIFA extrem Einzelspieler basiert ist. Das bedeutet, dass sich sehr viel auch auf den einzelnen Spieler fokussiert und weniger um das Team, die Organisation um diesen Spieler herum. Das ist etwas, was Sportvereine so nicht gewohnt sind. Es gibt tatsächlich Gründe, warum die klassischen großen E-Sport-Organisationen bis vor kurzem im Prinzip alle keine FIFA-Abteilung integriert hatten, weil FIFA eher ein einzelner Spieler-basierter Sport ist. Das kommt ja auch aus dem klassischen Sport. Warum haben Tennis-Spieler traditionell keine Sportvereine, die sie vertreten? Weil es auch ein einzelner Spieler-basiertes Thema ist. Das ist so ein bisschen die Problematik im FIFA-Bereich für uns Vereine, dass das das ganze Arbeiten etwas erschwert und umgekehrt wieder, was uns das Arbeiten beispielsweise im League-of-Legend-Bereich leichter macht, weil es hier tatsächlich um das Team geht und weniger um den einzelnen Spieler, was ja so eine Vereinstruktur eher beinhaltet. Von daher müssen wir mal sehen, wohin der Weg hier geht. Leider Gottes arbeitet EA und die FIFA auch sehr autark von den Vereinen und dann eher mit den Spielern direkt, was uns auch nicht wirklich gefällt, weil es letztendlich Angestellte von uns sind. Aber das sind tatsächlich Detailthemen, die glaube ich zu weit reichen würden. Und so viel Zeit haben wir auch nicht mehr.
Übrigens, kleiner Fun-Fact. Der einzige Fußballverein, dessen E-Sport-Abteilung gemeinnützig ist, zumindest Stand 4. April 2018, ist natürlich Raberleipzig. Wie könnte es auch anders sein? Was mich aber zum letzten Thema führt, das ich gerne noch besprechen wollen würde, nämlich, das haben wir vorhin schon angesprochen, Tim, als wir über euer Engagement im E-Sport gesprochen haben. Da ging es viel darum, dass man als Marke wahrgenommen werden möchte, dass man in einem Bereich aktiv sein möchte, in dem sich Jugendliche aufhalten, in dem auch Geld verdient wird. Und das hast du ja auch beschrieben. Ihr wollt damit auch Geld verdienen. Stellt sich aber ja die Frage, wie eigentlich? Also sollen sich denn irgendwann mal die Leute von euch dann E-Sport Merchandise kaufen? Wird es über die Preisgelder laufen? Was sind denn eigentlich da die Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten, die Schalke 04 anstrebt?
Also am Ende des Tages sind es im Prinzip alle Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten, die der Fußballverein auch besitzt, außer – und das ist der große Unterschied – und so ist ja im Prinzip die Monetarisierung Fußball begonnen. Und das gibt es im E-Sport gar nicht vom ersten Tag an. Quasi das Thema Ticketing, eigene Veranstaltungen. Das haben wir nicht, dass wir irgendwie über Zuschauereinnahmen, bzw. Ticketeinnahmen Geld verdienen und dann auch über Catering und so weiter und so weiter. So ist ja im Prinzip der professionelle Fußball entstanden damals, dass Leute dann auf einmal Geld bezahlt haben, um den Leuten zuzuschauen. Das haben wir bei uns nicht. Alles andere. Wir haben eine super spannende Zielgruppe, was wiederum für ganz viele Unternehmen interessant ist. Wir haben eine extrem emotionale Marke. Also das Thema Sponsoring ist extrem wichtig. Digitale Monetarisierung, sei es über Plattformen wie YouTube, sei es über Plattformen wie Twitch. Großes Thema bei uns. Preisgelder aktuell zumindest noch nicht wirklich relevant. Merchandise, du sagt es kommt irgendwann, besteht ja schon. Also wir verkaufen ja unser E-Sport-Trikot bereits. Wir verkaufen unseren E-Sport-Hoodie bereits. Alles natürlich.
Also läuft das? Läuft das? Also ich habe auch Rasenfunk-Merchandise, aber es waren ja 20 Shirts.
Also wir sind noch weit, weit, weit entfernt davon, den Merchandise-Volumen unserer Fußball-Abteilung konkurrieren zu können. Aber wir verkaufen eine relevante Anzahl an Trikots. Und ich glaube, hier ist ja eher die Vision und die Möglichkeit der Trigger, anstatt wir haben jetzt hier ein Produkt, das so fort funktioniert und millionenfach verkauft wird. Ich glaube, wir müssen uns hier auch unsere Wahrnehmung und unsere Marke auch erst mal erarbeiten. Aber wir schauen einfach mal rüber nach Amerika, Cloud9 oder TSM. Für die Zuschauer, die es wahrscheinlich nicht wissen, das sind so die größten E-Sport-Organisationen weltweit. Die haben siebenstellige Merchandise-Umsätze. Damit kann man ja relativ einfach sehen, wohin das führen kann. Aber vielleicht um die Frage zu vereinfachen. Grundsätzlich ist das Finanzierungsmodell exakt das gleiche wie im Fußballabzüglichen Stadion.
Wenn ich mal kurz nachfragen darf, ist das eigentlich euer Ziel, dass irgendwann – so läuft das ja auch in der Bundesliga – bei euch im Stadion was los ist? Das könnte ja im E-Sport auch nicht unmöglich sein. Aber aktuell ist es eben so, dass Veranstalter wie die ESL, also Turtle Entertainment, so etwas übernehmen. Findest du die Aufgabenverteilung richtig oder würdest du sagen, es ist ein Ziel, dass ihr auch irgendwann mal Leute in euer Stadion holt?
Also es ist relativ komplex, weil ein Event zu veranstalten benötigt ja im E-Sport dann auch extrem viel technisches Know-how, Equipment und so weiter und so weiter. Wir sind in dem Bereich absolut keine Experten. Wir sind Experten auf dem Gebiet, Sportveranstaltungen zu organisieren. Manchmal auch Events im Bereich Musik und so weiter. Ein E-Sport-Event auf die Beine zu stellen – ich meine, Malte, du weißt es sehr, sehr gut – ist schon sehr komplex. Wir hoffen und wir gehen auch davon aus, dass wir bei uns im Stadion irgendwann auch E-Sports-Evente haben werden. Ob es dann tatsächlich eigene Spiele sind, also dass wir irgendwie sagen, wir tragen unser Meisterschaftsspiel in League of Legends auf oder in welchem Spiel auch immer, ist denkbar. Ist aber noch nicht in naher Zukunft tatsächlich unmöglich. Man muss ja auch dabei noch sagen, E-Sport-Events füllen Stadien, füllen Arenen, aber da reden wir immer noch von 12.000, 15.000 Leuten und unsere Felchens Arena umfasst 62.000 Leute. Das ist nochmal eine andere Dimension und eine andere Hausnummer, das Stadion zu füllen. Ich glaube, wenn wir mal einen Zuschlag für die League of Legends Weltmeisterschaft bekommen würden oder für einen Major in CSGO, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sehr, sehr, sehr viele Zuschauer ins Stadion strömen. Aktuell, dass eins unserer Teams oder eins unserer Spieler ein Stadion füllt, so vermessen sind wir nicht, das zu glauben.
Und wie ist denn die Reaktion der Zuschauer auf das Engagement vom Bundesliga-Verein wie jetzt eben euch? Das muss man sich ja vorstellen, es gab ja schon vorher andere Teams. Es war ja nicht so, dass das mit Einstieg von anderen Sportvereinen in den E-Sport-Bereich gegründet wurde. Und da gibt es auch quasi den FC Bayern München des E-Sports und da gibt es schon quasi auch schon das Schalke 04 des E-Sports. Und dann kommt eben Schalke 04 und das sehr, sehr internationale Publikum des E-Sports denkt sich, bitte wer?
Also zum Glück sind wir als Fußballverein so bekannt, dass viele nicht bitte wer gesagt haben, sondern aha Schalke. Aber ja, in China und in den USA gab es natürlich auch Leute, die gesagt haben, bitte wer. Grundsätzlich, ich glaube Konni, du verfolgst die Community auch immer sehr, sehr stark, kann man sagen, dass es eher eine Begeisterung gab, dass jetzt auch große traditionelle Sportvereine sich diesem Thema widmen und damit ja auch dem Thema eine Anerkennung bieten und auch eine neue Berichterstattung darüber. Als dass es die Reaktion gab, oh nein, jetzt nehmen die uns den E-Sport weg, wie er mal war. Ich glaube, das ist so das Community-Feedback gewesen, zumindest aus meiner Wahrnehmung. Und die anderen Organisationen, ich glaube, da gab es auch so ein gemischtes Empfinden dabei. Also natürlich Fußballvereine, Sportvereine haben einen finanziellen Background, der gefährlich werden kann, also Konkurrenz stellen wir mit Sicherheit da. Umgekehrt bringen wir aber auch sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit in den Markt, was diesen Organisationen dann auch wieder extrem hilft. Also es ist da auch so eine Mischung aus beidem gewesen.
Also ich denke auch, dass es sich ganz gut gegenseitig befruchtet. Und ich kann eigentlich die Eindrücke von Tim auch nur so wiedergeben. Also ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass die Leute sich denken, oh Gott, was wollen jetzt denn die klassischen Vereine bei uns mit E-Sports? Haut bloß alle ab. Nee, ganz im Gegenteil. Also es wurde relativ positiv aufgefasst. Sieht man eigentlich auch ganz gut immer an den Social-Zahlen, also wie da reagiert wurde. Und doch, das war eher positiv, ja.
Gibt ja auch die Kooperationen. Also jetzt SK Gaming mit dem 1. FC Köln zum Beispiel, ein Traditions-Gaming-Team, ein Traditions-Husball-Verein, und man tauscht da wieder Expertise aus. Ich frage mich eher, wie das so in fünf bis zehn Jahren aussieht. Aber am Ende des Tages wird vielleicht einfach so das, was es an großen Teams gibt, nochmal ergänzt, um E-Sports-Teams, die es geschafft haben, mitzugehen. Es gibt jetzt ja auch E-Sports-Teams, die große Sponsoren reinholen oder auch Investoren, um da eben zu konkurrieren und wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben. Und ich glaube, das werden auch einige schaffen. Tim hat hier eben eine Marke wie Cloud9 oder ein Team wie Cloud9 angesprochen. Ich glaube, die werden sich einfach auch mit Schalke auf Augenhöhe begegnen können, auch noch in zehn Jahren. Ja, ich hatte da in der Vorbereitung häufiger den Vergleich – ihr müsst mir jetzt sagen, ob das schief ist – des Frauenfußballs, wo du eben auch etablierte Vereine hast, die auch eine Frauenfußballabteilung mit ihren Möglichkeiten in die Erste-Fußball-Bundesliga geführt haben, der FC Bayern, der VfL Wolfsburg und so weiter. Aber du hast eben auch noch Turbine-Potsdam, du hast noch FSC Frankfurt. Das heißt, Frauenfußball-Vereine, die da waren, bevor der professionelle Fußball, also der Männerfußball, das für sich entdeckt hat. Vielleicht könnte das eine Analogie sein. Außer ihr sagt mir, sie ist total schief. Okay, ihr seid auch einfach zu höflich. Das muss man an der Stelle sagen. Aber auf der anderen Seite stelle ich mir dann auch die Frage, wie verknüpft man denn dann eigentlich seine E-Sport-Abteilung mit dem eigentlich dahinterstehenden Verein? Also ich habe mir da Videos angeguckt, natürlich wie ihr das auf Schalke macht. Da kriegen dann die E-Sportler, die Gelsenkirchen zum Teil noch gar nicht aussprechen können, die kriegen dann eine Führung und ihnen wird erzählt, was für ein Verein dahinter steckt. Und das wird jetzt vermutlich jeder Verein machen. Also die Klubberer werden ihren E-Sportlern sagen, wir sind die, die immer gesagt wird, wir sind ein Depp, aber eigentlich sind wir ganz cool. Und der VfB Stuttgart macht das bei seinen anders. Aber so treten die ja in der Szene gar nicht auf. Gibt es da vielleicht auch noch so einfach zwei komplett verschiedene Welten, dass Leute mit einem Fußballhintergrund sich das Schalke 04 E-Sport Team angucken und sagen, ja klar, in der ersten Saison abgestiegen, das passt ja. Oder schon wieder nicht Meister geworden, das passt ja. Und die E-Sport Community, die vielleicht im Fußball nicht so tief drin ist, sich einfach nur denkt, okay, den Gamer, den kenne ich noch von daher, der ist total gut, wenn er – ja gut, da kenne ich mich jetzt leider nicht aus – mit der rechten Maustaste hier den Adler hüpfen lassen muss.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist es ganz klar, dass wir uns auch unsere eigene Identität im E-Sport erst mal erarbeiten müssen. Was wir, was du ja schon gerade gesagt hast, natürlich machen, ist es unseren E-Sportlern die Schalke Welt näher zu bringen. Und das bedeutet aber nicht, dass jetzt unsere E-Sportler auf einmal Fußballverrückt sind und unser Steigerlied rauf und runter singen können. Das können auch viele unserer Fußballer nicht. Viele unserer Fußballer sind auch nicht, nur weil sie dann nach Schalke wechseln auf einmal Gelsenkirchener durch und durch. Das ist ja auch naiv zu glauben. Aber es gibt hier Identitäten und Werte des Vereins, die wollen wir unseren Spielern vermitteln. Und das geht aber auch nicht von jetzt auf gleich. Und das geht auch nicht, wir laden die einmal nach Schalke ein, lassen die in ein Spiel gucken und die haben es verinnerlicht. Ich glaube, das entwickelt sich dann, umso länger ein Spieler bei uns in der Organisation ist, umso mehr weiß er Schalke zu lieben und zu schätzen und auch unsere Werte zu verstehen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, in allen Bereichen, im klassischen Sport, im E-Sport, in was auch immer ist es gleich. Man kann ja nicht erwarten, verpflichtet jemanden, der hat direkt das Schalke-Virus gepackt. So funktioniert die Welt ja nicht. Und ich glaube, wir tun auch sehr gut daran, tatsächlich hier eine sehr eigene Art der Kommunikation aufrechtzuerhalten, wenn die Zielgruppe, die hier E-Sport lebt und liebt, ist anders als der Fußballfan oftmals. Und so müssen wir mit ihm ja da und auch reden, kommunizieren und wie es so schön immer heißt, im digitalen Engagement betreiben.
Damit wäre auch hier mal ein Bingozettel jetzt dann voll der Anglizismen, die in dieser Folge verwendet wurden. Dann würde ich euch alle drei gerne nochmal abschließend zu einer Zukunftsvision oder um eine Zukunftsvision bitten. Vielleicht fangen wir mal bei Konni an. 2025, Deutschland. Was wird am Wochenende mehr geguckt? E-Sport-Veranstaltungen oder die Fußball-Bundesliga?
Die Fußball-Bundesliga.
Warum?
Also ich glaube, ich habe ja auch schon einige Prognosen gehört und das ist ja immer so ein bisschen, man kann ja damit richtig liegen oder falsch. Aber ich glaube, dass der Fußball in seiner klassischen Form in Deutschland und in der Kultur so derbe verankert ist, dass FIFA oder was auch immer bis dahin für ein Fußballspiel sich durchsetzen wird, es sehr schwer haben werden, dem Fußball den Titel strittig zu machen. Aber ich glaube, bis dahin wird auf jeden Fall die Reichweite und auch die Zuschauerschaft deutlich nach oben gehen, aber immer noch weit weg vom klassischen Fußball, denke ich.
Malte, wie denkst du über die Zukunft 2025? Welchen Rang wird eSport haben? Also ich muss dazu nochmal sagen, dass ich finde, dass man eSports auch ein bisschen zerteilen muss. Also jedes Spiel ist ein Sport an sich. Und ich finde, dass für einen Fußball jetzt ein bisschen hart mit allen Sportarten auf einmal konkurrieren zu müssen, aber das kriegt der Fußball, denke ich, schon hin. Also ich würde sagen, 2025 immer noch Fußball so die wichtigste Sportart, aber ich glaube, eSports in der Gänze, also alle Spiele zusammengerechnet, werden da schon nahe rankommen und dann Nummer zwei dann sein.
Also ich hatte auch die Frage so verstanden, wie FIFA im Vergleich zur Bundesliga abschneidet. Wenn wir natürlich eSport komplett nehmen, Ich meinte eSport komplett, ja. Okay, dann würde ich, was FIFA und Bundesliga angeht, bleibe ich bei meiner Meinung. Ansonsten ist das sehr schwer abzuschätzen. Wir bekommen es immer wieder mit, dass teilweise eSportstitel, die etabliert waren, dann wieder nicht mehr so den Stellenwert genießen, neue Spiele dazukommen, eben Fortnite oder sowas. Das ist unfassbar schwer. Aber wir sehen es ja jetzt schon bei Einschaltquoten im Vergleich zu klassischen Sportwettbewerben. Die sind ja jetzt schon teilweise höher als die NBA-Finals zum Beispiel. Deswegen würde ich da zumindest sagen, mindestens auf Augenhöhe, wenn nicht sogar der eSport ein bisschen weiter vorne ist. Und Malte hat eine Sache wichtig angeschnitten, ich weiß, Tim muss gleich los. Nur ganz kurz, eSport ist sozusagen wirklich der Oberbegriff. Und diese ganzen Spiele sind die Sportarten. Ich glaube, das muss man auch immer wieder noch im Hinterkopf behalten.
So, und Tim, jetzt noch deine Prognose. Wo steht der eSport und wo steht dann Schalke 04? Sag jetzt bitte nicht an der Weltspitze.
Also tatsächlich sage ich auch, Fußball wird wahrscheinlich für immer Zuschauersport Nummer 1 in Deutschland bleiben. Ich gehe ein bisschen weiter als Malte und Konni hier und sage, dass es ein Computerspiel geben wird, also ein Titel, wie wir im Fachjargon sagen, dass es einen Titel geben wird, der die Nummer 2 in Deutschland sein wird. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es ein Computerspiel geben wird, das mehr geschaut wird als alle anderen Sportarten in Deutschland. Welchen weiß ich, kann ich jetzt nicht so genau sagen, aber da bin ich mir sehr sehr sicher. Und das sind meine Prognosen hier. Ich glaube allerdings, dass der Fußball immer das Kind des Deutschen bleiben wird. Und wo steht Schalke? Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass wir zu den etablierten Traditionsvereinen im E-Sport gehören werden. Das ist dann in 25 Jahren oder wann auch immer möglich zu sagen, wir haben Tradition.
Dann freuen wir uns schon alle auf die E-Sportler, die nach dem Sieg der Schalke wappen küssen und den großen Transfer, wo dann der E-Sportler sagt, ich habe schon früher in Schalke E-Sport, Bett, Wäsche geschlafen. Das werden herrliche Zeiten. Ich danke euch allen zuvorderst Tim Reichert, Chief Gaming Officer des FC Schalke 04, bei Twitter, Tim Reichert14, Tim, vielen Dank für deine Zeit. Und außerdem danke an Malte Hedderich, selbst FIFA-Spieler, Experte der Tobias Escher des E-Sports im FIFA-Bereich. Er würde das selber so nicht zugeben, aber so ist es einfach. Ed Malte Hedderich auf Twitter und Teil vom Beepard Gaming, den kann man beiden sehr gerne folgen. Malte, vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Das freut mich. Und Spaß gemacht hat es auch, Konni Winkler zuzuhören. Ed Konni auf Twitter, es lohnt sich sehr, ihm dort zu folgen, denn da bekommt man einen perfekten Mix aus Fußball-Content und E-Sport-Content. Ich möchte Konni sehr, sehr empfehlen an alle meine Hörerinnen und Hörer. Lieben Dank dir, Konni, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke dir und schön, dass es mal geklappt hat.
Ja, das finde ich auch. Und auch danke an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die Interesse an dieser Folge hatte. Das war Tribünengespräch Nr. 17. Hört euch auch die anderen 16 an. Da geht es dann ein bisschen um härtere Fußball-Themen in diesem Sinne. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie häufig der E-Sport hier noch stattfinden wird im Rasenfunk. Meine Prognose? Gar nicht so selten. Da werden wir uns alle dran gewöhnen. Und bis dahin weiß ich dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mehr. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören, macht's gut, bis bald, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.